entgegen möglicher befürchtungen zeigte
sich us präsident donald trump überaus
zufrieden mit dem nato gipfel in brüssel
bei seiner pressekonferenz vor
internationalen journalisten sagte trump
wir sind jetzt sehr glücklich wir haben
eine stärkere nato als noch vor zwei
tagen
es war ein gutes treffen weil wir uns
gut verstanden haben alle im raum haben
zugesagt mehr zu zahlen und schneller zu
zahlen
generalsekretär stoltenberg mit ihnen
was auch gleich sagen er hat mir gedankt
jeder im raum hat mir gedankt
es gab einen echten kollegialen
geistigen im raum die usa bekennt sich
weiterhin in studien zur nato immer
wieder hatte trump deutschland direkt
für zu geringe zahlungen in den nato
haushalt kritisiert und gesagt
deutschlands abhängigkeit zu russland in
puncto energieversorgung sei ein
sicherheitsrisiko
nun zeigte er sich persönlich
deutschland wird immer besser
wir müssen jetzt noch sehen was mit
einer pipeline passiert denn wie kommt
immerhin aus russland niemand hat das
angesprochen nur ich und jetzt reden
alle jetzt redet die ganze welt aber
vielleicht haben ja auch alle ein gutes
verhältnis zu russland und dann ist die
pipeline kein problem auch über sein
verhältnis zu russland sprach trump
direkt zumal er russlands präsident
wladimir putin nur wenige tage nach dem
gipfeltreffen wird
er ist ein konkurrent jemand habe nicht
gefragt ist
er ist nicht mein fall ist er ein freund
verkehr wenn ich ihn getroffen habe
haben wir uns gut verstanden
ob man davon ausgehen könne dass er an
einem tweet alles zurücknehmen werde
sobald er in der air force one sitzt
wollte einer der journalisten wissen
andere machen sowas vielleicht ich nicht
ich bin sehr konsistent
ich bin ein sehr stabiles genie